meet Clark he's got everything a good
job good friends everything but he
always felt a little flung from space
people hate what they don't understand
but he's about to meet someone who
finally makes him feel at home
who's then Clark Kent Daily Planet Bruce
Wayne meets Clark Kent I love it
I love bringing people together how are
we now they've got to figure out if
heroes from two different planets can
get vulnerable get real and even fall in
love you are the the epitome of
everything I have ever looked for in
another human being I can't stand next
to you without wanting to hold you I
love you this spring
from Warner Brothers pictures when the
past comes back to heroes must decide
what's really worth fighting for he
would you I thought yours you little
hypocritical point yourself Batman meets
Superman dawn of justice I love you I
had to set him
you